just think of it as a jaunty stroll in
the woods what could possibly go wrong
in the forest of the night i know this
is crazy late coming out i warned you
this was gonna happen though so don't
complain to me so this episode starts
with a really intriguing premise which
is basically that
a global forest every land mass on the
planet has grown this massive amount of
trees they're covering everything it's
happened on and nowhere it has happened
immediately nobody knows how nobody
knows why and that's just a great doctor
who kind of set up right there although
if i'm being honest this episode overall
is probably the weakest of series eight
so far now having said that it's still
really good i would not call it a bad
episode which just speaks to how strong
this series has been overall so far
there's a lot of good stuff that goes on
here the stuff that happens with clara
again it's just really solid her dynamic
with the doctor especially i just at
this point i really enjoy their
relationship i like the fact that she's
not traveling with him constantly and
rather he picks her up from time to time
i like that right now especially she
kind of has a better sense of him than
he even has of himself and with the way
that capaldi's playing the doctor i
actually really like that dynamic again
i keep going back to the same thing i
don't want her to stick around forever
but they're wrapping her up in a really
great way assuming that she is leaving
at the end of the series which is my
assumption that's the vibe i'm getting
the doctor himself
he's slightly off from me in this
episode not in the overall performance
it's fine but he's a little more at
least initially dismissive of children
than i think we've ever seen him one of
the things that was always kind of nice
especially with the matt smith version
was how he related better and easier to
children than he did to adults and i
really liked that aspect and i guess
this just kind of hammers home the fact
that this is not gonna be the same he's
not gonna have that thing that matt
smith had going which is fine it just it
happened to be one of my favorite
aspects of that character so it was kind
of a little sad for me to really get it
hammered home that that's not the case
anymore now that said he's not
completely dismissive of children but
the way he kind of brushes them off uh
in the early parts of this episode you
made me go a little bit no
whoa all right if you're gonna be grumpy
i guess you go all out danny pink more
solid work as we've been seeing there's
a lot of really good character work as
there has been across the whole series i
think it's the story itself is probably
the weakest thing while the initial
setup is intriguing what's actually done
with it is a little odd because you know
as i said it is global it's the entire
planet covered in this forest but we're
only dealing with this little sort of
section of london we deal with sort of
the microcosm of it which i guess can
work but it it puts things a little out
of proportion because all we're dealing
with is like this little group of kids
on a school trip and the doctor yeah
we're trying to deal with these global
implications as well it's a little out
of balance in that sense and then it
goes for a lot of very obvious things
like the fact that one of the kids gets
lost in is in a red-hooded overcoat
thing and yes there are wolves so hey
little red white are you a big bad wolf
it's it's a little too on the nose and
it does come back to some of the notions
that the doctor gives towards the end of
the episode so they they're not
completely out of place thematically but
i it's just such the obvious way to go i
kind of wish they hadn't and then the
actual resolution and the way it it pans
out i kind of like the explanation for
what it is that happens but the way that
it actually pans out i i don't know what
it was about it just came off to me as a
bit cheesy a little bit too cut and dry
ah no problem actually kill the moon had
the same issue with the resolution so
this isn't the first time the series
that an episode has sort of not quite
stuck the landing a little bit i do
think kill the moon was slightly more
successful overall as an episode than
this one is but they're kind of a double
act in terms of themes and the way the
story plays out with similar strengths
similar weaknesses we've got part one of
our two part finale airing tonight which
means we're finally gonna get a better
sense of whoever the heck missy is we
may not find out exactly but we're
definitely gonna spend more time with
her do you have a theory as to who she
is do you think she is some version of
someone we've seen before or do you
think she's an altogether new character
whatever it is that you think drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned